[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
débattre discuter et réfléchir sur les
grands enjeux qui font l'actualité
le thème de ce soir la violence dans le
football amateur
plus de onze mille trois cents match
entaché d'incidents recensés dans le
football amateur c'est le bilan présenté
par la fédération française de football
et l'observatoire national de la
délinquance et des réponses pénales pour
la saison 2017-2018
des rencontres qui ne représente qu 1 8%
du total mais qui marque à l'époque une
augmentation une violence qui gâche la
joie de l'équipe vainqueur et le plaisir
des joueurs et des spectateurs
alors comment l'endiguer trois invités
avec nous ce soir pour échanger sur ce
sujet jean pierre mur meurillon pardon
président du district de football des
yvelines bonsoir bonsoir et en visio
sébastien doriano arbitre de district et
président de la section départementale
de l'union nationale des arbitres de
football bonsoir bonsoir et guiga
lentilles président de l'étoile sportive
de guyancourt bonsoir bonsoir à tous
alors le 25 octobre dernier le match de
3e division opposant sartrouville et
saint germain en yvelines est arrêté
larbitre a été agressé par un spectateur
d'entrer sur le terrain le 11 octobre
c'est dans le val d'oise
ce sont des informations que l'on voit
régulièrement dans les pages de la
presse locale jean pierre moriau
combien de matchs sont joués chaque
saison dans le district des yvelines on
a un peu moins de
de 10000 match donnait la saison
dernière on en a eu évidemment un peu
moins 6800 à peu près et comme vous
l'avez dit le nombre de cas où il y à
des incidents sérieux c'est
effectivement 1,8 au niveau national
pour la saison dernière dans le district
des yvelines ça a été un virgule 44 donc
on est en dessous de la moyenne ce qui
est déjà ce qui est déjà bien tout
simplement ce qu'on peut constater c'est
que malheureusement la violence pas
seulement dans le football mais dans le
sport en général c'est celle reflet de
la société et pour autant il faut pas
qu'on accepte et qu'on se résigne
il faut néanmoins prendre les choses les
choses en main et le but est contre eux
soit on a dit c'est un pourcentage qui
est finalement dérisoire vers toutes les
rencontres qu'on peut voir on a quand
même la sensation d'en entendre parler
quasiment chaque week-end est ce que ça
peut être aussi un manque de
transparence des informations qui ne
remonte pas où des incidents qui sont
moins graves que d'autres dont ton nom
ne pas non d'ailleurs lors de
l'assemblée générale du district chaque
année on donne les chiffres je les ai là
sous les yeux
la saison dernière quand je parle de
sanction grave il s'agit de sanctions
qui commence à 6 mois de suspension et
au delà il y en avait 18 la saison
dernière 19 la saison d'avant saison
dernière elle a été quand même moins
moins longue mais 25 ans de 17,2 en
2017-2018 27 l'année d'avant on
s'aperçoit qu'on est à peu près constant
malheureusement mais vous dites que il y
en a peu c'est vrai mais il y en a trop
et comment est-ce qu'on est qu'on peut
expliquer que des matchs puissent
dégénérer
j'avoue que ça m'a toujours ça m'a
toujours surpris parce que l'enjeu
certes c'est d'essayer de gagner le
match mais nous sommes dans le sport
amateur je veux dire l'enjeu
il est simplement de se faire plaisir de
jouer au foot parce qu'on aime le jeu
parce qu'on aime le sport et en
particulier le football et c'est assez
c'est assez surprenant alors c'est vrai
que l'on peut être passionné à un point
qui fait qu'à un moment donné on perd un
petit peu pied mais c'est pas c'est pas
tolérable geek et lentilles en tant que
président de club à ce que j'imagine
vous êtes aussi attentifs à cette
violence est ce que vous en parlez de
vous licencier
bien sûr bien sûr ça nous arrive aussi
d'avoir des joueurs qui ont des
comportements répréhensibles l'est
effectivement c'est un sujet très
important abordé dans le club dans mon
club en particulier
j'avoue qu'on n'a pas les mêmes outils
en main que la fédération les ligues ou
le district voire même de du maine on
n'est pas des officiers d'état civil ni
des juges et de ce fait nos actions
internes sont très limités on peut
malheureusement pas intervenir et
notamment sur un cac est très précis
c'est les supporters on peut agir en
interne sur les joueurs les éducateurs
de nos dirigeants dirigeante mais on est
impuissant mais vraiment impuissant
devant
des gens qui viennent voir les matchs et
on issus du taq s'est d'ailleurs de dire
que ce sont nos supporters et
quelquefois c'est plutôt l inverse se
sont pas nos supporters mais des
supporters adverses il y est né et tout
ça provoque un malaise général on dit
respect de la civilité
j'en passe et des meilleurs justement
jean pierre gremion les petits clubs
c'est pas comme les grands clubs on peut
pas interdire de stade en spectateur non
en tout cas les instances du football
n'ont passé n'ont pas cette possibilité
l'interdiction de la présence de
spectateurs c'est ça peut être une
sanction lorsqu'il y a eu des incidents
graves
c'est ce qu'on appelle un match à huis
clos mais c'est extrêmement difficile
ensuite à faire respecter il nous faut
le concours de la police ou de la
gendarmerie
bien entendu il nous faut aussi
travailler avec les la mairie de là où
les choses se sont passées mais c'est
vrai qu'avec à l'égard des spectateurs
c'est pour nous un instant c'est
compliqué pour le club ça l'est tout
autant
on entend aussi souvent c'est la faute
de l'arbitré c'est de la part des
joueurs c'est de la part des spectateurs
aussi dans les deux premiers exemples
d'agression que je citais plutôt d'air
c'était des arbitres les victimes
sébastien soriano est ce que c'est
difficile aujourd'hui d'arbitrer un
match difficile d'arbitrer un match je
dirais que non la plus grande difficulté
c'est de réussir à faire passer
l'information auprès des joueurs je vous
dirais que depuis de nombreuses années
on a cette joie l'amour qui nous protège
et qui nous donne le droit
un cadre légal supplémentaires qui
n'existaient pas précédemment qui fait
que pour la plupart des joueurs c'est à
dire toutes les personnes on va dire
même l'encadrement présence sur la
feuille de match informatisé fait que
voilà on est capable de les cadrer est
de savoir s'il ya un souci
le district et ses commissions de
discipline et d'instruction vont prendre
les choses en main et à ce niveau là on
aura aucun souci pour le cas dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure sur saint germain
on est dans cette problématique
extérieur de d'un spectateur qui lui
n'est pas connue n'est pas notifiée sur
la feuille de match informatisé et où
j'ai envie de dire on va avoir cette
problématique qui existent de assez
souvent de ce compte rendu
on va avoir entre le la sanction
sportive qui est pris par le district
quand certains licenciés quand c'est
quelqu'un qui est connu
du monde du football et d'un spectateur
dont parlait matthieu meurillon tout à
l'heure où monsieur galanti on n'a pas
toujours une prise dessus
parfois on connaît parfois on ne connaît
pas et là dans le cadre en tout cas qui
nous concerne pour les yvelines c'est
vrai que c'est la plus grosse
problématique c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'union nationale des arbitres de
football que je représente entre autres
va avoir cette difficulté de pouvoir
poursuivre
l'individu qui a agressé notre collègue
puisque à l'heure d'aujourd'hui on n'a
toujours pas ça tout s'est toujours pas
qui est cette personne
on n'a pas le nom prénom et ça ça pose
quand même ça pose des soucis parce
qu'on a la chance dans notre district
d'avoir dû des sanctions qui ont été
dédoublées depuis de nombreuses années
il ya un travail qui est effectué par le
district des yvelines de phu tho sur
justement la protection de l' arbitre et
de l'arbitrage en général ainsi que des
joueurs puisque il arrive aussi de temps
à autre que ce soit des joueurs entre
eux qui s'adresse pour différentes
raisons et c'est vrai qu'à ce niveau là
au niveau de la maison football des
yvelines
il ya toujours eu une prise de
responsabilité qui a toujours été grande
et qu'elle l'est encore aujourd'hui
maintenant se pose cette question de
comment on va pouvoir sanctionner des
personnes qui ne sont pas des licenciés
de clubs hantise agresse un arbitre est
là aujourd'hui je vous dirais que l'unaf
en tout cas attend avec impatience de
pouvoir trouver là l'identité de cette
personne qui a remplacé notre collègue
et le 25 octobre
vous disiez aussi il y a il ya aussi
parfois le problème avec les joueurs
parce que selon l'observatoire national
de la délinquance sur les buts que dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure
89% des personnes commettant l'acte de
violence le plus grave ce sont les
joueurs et ce sont ces les premières
victimes 57%
pourtant dans les barèmes disciplinaire
ce sont les peines parfois les moins
lourde pour les joueurs par exemple pour
la saison 2010 9 2020 un joueur comme
étant un comportement grossier ou un jeu
lieu à l'encontre d'un officiel il
risque quatre matches de suspension et
une amende de 20 euros
l'entraîneur éducateur ou dirigeant
risque lui dix matches de suspension et
une amende de 50 euros
si déjà pour gérer sur le terrain est ce
qu'il faudrait pas sanctionner plus
lourdement les joueurs et qu'ils se
rendent compte de l'impact que ça va
peut avoir pour un club jean-pierre
mourillon
vous avez raison et c'est pour cette
raison que le district des yvelines de
football en 2002 a été le premier en
france en france a augmenté le barème
fédéral nous avons été les premiers à le
faire dès que ça a été possible et c'est
comme c'est désormais doki 2014 les
barèmes sont sains sont aggravées dans
tous les districts de l'île de france et
dans la ligue de l'île de france et ils
sont aggravées ça c'est une première
chose mais ensuite il faut les appliquer
et en ce qui nous concerne les
commissions de discipline dont je
rappelle qu'elles sont souveraine et
indépendante
moi je ne me mêle jamais de discipline
bien nos commissions disney appliquer
effectivement les sanctions qui sont
prévues par notre barème aggravée je
m'explique alors je vais illustrer mon
propos
si vous risquez
si vous risquez vous avez fait les faits
répréhensibles et puis que vous risquez
un an de prison on vous tire les
oreilles chez nous quand vous bousculé
un arbitre après le match il prend le
risque c'est de prendre l'intéressé
encourent un an de suspension
il prend 20 ans de suspension les applis
les appliquons nous appliquons et ça je
pense que c'est important et ce qu'il
faut c'est non seulement qu'on les
applique mais ensuite quand on l'a
appliqué il faut le faire savoir
tr montrer aux autres à l'ensemble des
licenciés que les règles qui sont
applicables et bien nous les appliquons
effectivement et dia lanthier justement
sur cette notion sachant que
l'encadrement peut parfois risqué plus
que le joueur voulait sensibiliser
notamment encore plus vos joueurs en
vous disant l'an 10 ans essayez de vous
contrôler peut-être profiter du match
joué en réalité ce qui est très
difficile entre les mots et les actions
c'est de généraliser le discours
l'ensemble des licenciés du club fille
garçon
en réalité moi je suis effectivement et
jean-pierre me rayon l'a précisé
pour sanctionner lourdement mais
lourdement les joueurs fautifs
et là j'y ferai un petit peu entre
parenthèses et non pas le club le joueur
parce que il parce qu'il ya des fois des
comportements qui sont inadmissibles
il ya aussi des concepts peut-être qu'on
aurait recherchés nous en interne on
essaie de former nos jeunes à
l'arbitrage en tout cas connaître les
règles je m'aperçois de plus en plus que
des joueurs des éducateurs des
dirigeants ne connaissent pas toutes les
règles les conteste on voit des fois des
situations ubuesques sur le sur le bord
de touche où l' arbitre et reprit alors
que il applique la règle mais la règle
n'est pas connu donc ça il ya peut-être
aussi et là je parle en tant
qu'éducateur un concept qui fera
peut-être qu'on utilise
on en a déjà parlé on a déjà évoqué d'un
espèce de permis
pour les éducateurs parce que là aussi
les éducateurs sont à mettre en première
ligne
e.on la maîtrise entre guillemets du jeu
de leurs joueurs
je crois qu'il ya peut-être quelque
chose à faire enfin et je crois que
c'est une mesure qui serait peut-être à
adapter comme le font nos amis du rugby
l'exclusion temporaire elles existent
chez nos jeunes pas assez à mon avis
utilisé elle devrait être généralisé
jusqu'aux vétérans des plus jeunes aux
vétérans
je crois que ce serait déjà une avancée
que de permettre et je crois que
sébastien sera d'accord avec moi que de
permettre de calmer un joueur je sais
que en tout cas pour l'avoir vu
sebastian est très pédagogue de calmer
un joueur de pouvoir le recadrer sur la
touche et le faire rentrer plutôt que
d'utiliser des cartons rouges qui des
fois provoque des comportements et sur
le terrain et en dehors du terrain à
cause justement de sanctions très
sévères pareti nous donc il me semble
très sévère justement sébastien soriano
est ce que vous adapter aussi vos
manière d'arbitrer en fonction des
matchs vous allez être plus sensible sur
un match vous savez que ça peut
s'accrocher et laissez passer peut-être
des petites fautes sur des matchs qui
vont se dérouler tranquillement comme je
dis souvent mon capitaine dans mon
vestiaire avant le début du match je
reste un être humain et donc à partir de
là inévitablement vous arrivez comme les
joueurs avec bonne humeur du jour même
si on nous demande de les mettre de côté
un comme un joueur qui va arriver sont
un à qui on demandera la même chose mais
il est une évidence que vous arrivez sur
un terrain
avec l' envie que les choses se passent
au mieux et inévitablement quand vous
rencontrez des joueurs avec lesquels
vous avez une communication qui
s'installe que dès que vous leur
expliquer quelque chose vous entendez un
retour forcément vous avez envie de
prendre ce temps là de l'explication de
la pédagogie
à partir du moment où en face de vous
vous voyez que vous avez des plans qui
sont complètement fermés et ça arrive
aussi sur certains matches parce que il
ya une priorité parce qu'ils ont un
souvenir d'une fois où vous êtes venu et
ça a été un peu compliqué et voilà donc
on reste dans un an reste dans dans
quelque chose d'une relation humaine et
cette relation humaine il ya des fois
elle fonctionne du début à la fin et il
ya des fois elle fonctionne un peu moins
et c'est là qu'on doit je dirais nous
arbitre doubler à nouveau de pédagogie
est bon je pense qu'on est on est des
passionnés du football des lois du jeu
et que c'est là qu'on doit essayer un
maximum de pouvoir les transmettre
et c'est vrai que le meilleur match pour
un arbitre j'ai digéré et quant à la fin
du match on nous explique que assez bien
aujourd'hui et on en a vu un arbitre qui
a expliqué les choses à nos joueurs que
donc de les sanctionner comme utiliser
le monsieur galanti tout à l'heure après
faut-il encore avoir en face de nous des
gens susceptibles d'entendre et
d'écouter ce qu'on leur peut leur
proposer
ne serait ce que par une exclusion une
exclusion temporaire
peut-être pour le comprennent et qu'ils
se calment oui mais j'ai envie de dire
aux jeunes
je pense que tu es pédagogique je sais
pas si un enseignant en vétérans ça le
serait b a essayé peut être à mettre en
place
justement on parle des jeunes dans le
livre noir du sport patrick karam est
mal accueilli la grosse mettant en avant
que la valeur de la performance et de la
victoire à tout prix dépasse parfois la
mission sportive et en 2013 patrick
wincke anciens cadres de la fédération
française de football annoncé que cette
fédération envisage notamment de
modifier l'organisation pour les jeunes
jusqu'à 13 ans voire 15 ans ce ne serait
plus des montées et des descentes mais
plutôt un aspect éducatif est ce qu'il
faudrait pas aussi
modifier aussi les compétitions peut
être oublié un petit peu ces
championnats alors oui jusqu'à déjà
jusque jusqu'aux u13 jusqu'à ceux qui
ont moins de 13 ans il ya quasiment pas
de compétition 1 ça commence à partir
des réseaux sociaux moins de 14 ans il
ya des ligues et des districts où les
choses se passent de cette façon mais il
s'avère que le football c'est aussi un
sport de compétition quoi et donc c'est
parfois un peu compliqué que la
compétition ne soit pas c'est un peu de
l'adrénaline si vous voulez mais il faut
que ça reste dans les limites de ce
qu'il faut faire
on parlait des arbitres tout à l'heure
quand ya pas d arbitre le club et les
joueurs le regrettent
et dès qu'il ya un arbitre il le
critique c'est quand même paradoxal très
juste a ajouté que nous avons dans
district des yvelines un poids un type
particulier on a un système de bonus
malus sur les points qui sont donnés au
classement donc si indirectement sur les
montées et les descentes en fonction du
nombre de cartons jaunes des
avertissements et en fonction du nombre
de cartons rouges c'est à dire les axes
ou et de l'importance des suspensions
alors ça nous sommes quelques districts
à le faire dans la liste dans la ligue
de paris ile de france et c'est quelque
chose qui fonctionne parce que
effectivement ça veut dire que le
comportement d'un joueur ou d'un
d'éducateurs l'égard d'un arbitre peut
avoir in fine et des conséquences sur le
classement et ça les éducateurs et les
présidents et les joueurs aussi ils en
sont conscients et bigard lentilles on
disait à certains clubs c'est difficile
et relations avec les arbitres quand il
est là on est pas content quand il est
pas là on est content à guyancourt
comment ça se passe sur vos matchs qui
on est un des leurs puisque jacques a
déjà au moins d'un match qui peut se
tenir dans de bonnes conditions
effectivement les rapports avec les
arbitres et l'agent rejoint un peu
sébastien s'il arbitres et pédagogue bon
et accepte le contact avec les
éducateurs avant le match et c est qu il
explique tout se passe très bien
l'arbitré fait partie du jeu les parties
intégrantes du jeu sans lui il n'y a pas
de jeu et donc on a besoin d'un arbitre
alors je le dis il ya des fois comme
tout à chacun
quand on regarde un match à la télé on
dirait un arbitre a fait bon ça arrive à
tout le monde mais ça doit durer
l'espace d'une réflexion c'est tout
après un arbitre je crois que sans lui
de toute manière et jean pierre grand le
président et sans arbitre c'est très
difficile de faire des matches
aujourd'hui parce que les compétitions
veulent que voilà il ya de l'adrénaline
qui se met dans le jeu et ça favorise
des comportements quelquefois
inadmissible en cette époque où les
nouvelles technologies sont un peu
partout est ce qu'on pourrait pas
envisagé
un jour de filmer toutes les rencontres
pour notamment comme à saint germain de
pouvoir identifier les personnes qui
agresse pouvoir replacer aussi les
situations les arbitres sur certains
matches on s'le sont rois ou seul ça
peut être compliqué ils n'ont pas les
yeux partout ils doivent faire confiance
à des gens qui ont aussi des enjeux lors
d'un match alors ma réponse et dix mille
matches par an donc ce serait
effectivement très compliqué il arrive
quelques fois qu'on est des images ça
arrive que des clubs film leur match et
dans lequel à la commission de
discipline peut éventuellement sur servi
encore qu'il faut aussi regarder les
choses de très près parce que s'il ya
une brutalité d'un joueur envers un
autre joueur faut pas seulement nous
montrer cette brutalité mais peut-être
ce qui s'est passé quelques minutes
avant et il faut quand même faire aussi
faire aussi attention une précision tout
à l'heure je parlais de sanctions graves
quelques fois la sanction elle dure très
longtemps c'est de jean trois ans quatre
ans cinq ans de suspension et même
quelquefois plus s'achète dans le
district des yvelines jamais je dis bien
jamais il n'est procédé à une remise de
peine jamais celui qui a été acquis a
été infligée il ya trois ans 50
suspension trois ans après les mérites
toujours il n'ya aucune raison de dire
allez bon finalement au bout de quatre
ans va passer l'épongé et c'est celui
qui a pris 50 suspension il
il fera cinq ans de suspension on parle
de ses suspensions
chaque semaine nous on fait un sondage
auprès de nos téléspectateurs alors pour
ce numéro la question c'était celle ci
les fédérations sont elles laxiste
contre les responsables de violences
dans des matches amateurs
la réponse est oui à 90 % est ce que ces
liens aussi au fait que comme on est au
niveau amateur toutes les information ne
circule pas nécessairement et on ne voit
que ce qui apparaît aussi dans la presse
peut-être finalement non nous nous avons
pour chaque match
une feuille de match sur lequel arbitre
indique ce qui a pu se passer et les
feuilles de match sont sont examinés par
le district et puis elles sont
transmises quand il ya eu des incidents
et les et les rapports que font les
arbitres sont transmises à la commission
de discipline et ensuite la commission
discipline elle traite tous les dossiers
qui lui seront transmis
guy hands 6 il fallait proposer ce soir
une solution vous avez une minute à nous
proposer ce serait trop simple ça serait
ce serait magique même de dire ça en
tout cas ce que je voulais dire c'est
que ces violences discriminations
optimisation il faut aussi qu'on ait le
courage de parler de dire attention
attention à la création de clubs
communautaires
je vois de plus en plus peut-être pas
dans le foot à onze dans le futsal
notamment on a une équipe futsal donc je
dis attention soyons vigilants
aujourd'hui la société me montrent tous
ces maux le football c'est le reflet de
la société dont on retrouve dans le
football des comportements des jeunes
justement qu'ils doivent être
sanctionnés répréhensible et sanctionner
lourdement et je demande de plus en plus
et je crois qu'il est important de
signaler de signaler tous ces
agissements
il faut absolument les signaler et vous
avez raison il ya peut-être une chose ou
manque beaucoup
c'est de faire connaître les sanctions
plus encore qu'ils sont bien sûr
communiquer dans les journaux du
district ou de la ligue mais il faut
absolument que les sanctions soient
connus lorsqu'elles sont cder et hauteur
des faits qui sont reprochés
et vous savez sampdoria nos si vous
aviez une solution à proposer ce soir
pour que le foot reste du football
si on avait su on avait cette solution
je pense que ça fait longtemps qu'on
l'aurait appliqué comme vous disiez tout
à l'heure j'ai certains de mes collègues
qui sont tout seuls au centre il y en
ad'autres on a la chance de tourner à 3
je vous aimerai que la seule chose qui a
été essayée dans d'autres districts
c'est une go pro sur les arbitres il
permettrait de temps en temps de
peut-être sur certains matchs en tout
cas d'avoir un réel compte rendu de de
l'ambiance et de ce que je vis un
arbitre et c'est vrai que ça ça pourrait
faire partie peut-être des commentaires
de d'une forme de non pas de publicité
mais d'information qui pourrait y avoir
au près de 2 de certains clubs et
équipes dirigeants de se rendre compte
parfois ce que peut vivre un arbitre au
centre du terrain et c'est vrai que ça
pourrait peut-être avoir son intérêt sur
certains matches donc voilà mais voilà
je tiens quand même y miser un petit peu
les choses dans le bon sens du terme
une agression comme l'a vécu notre
collègue ça faisait quatre ans que ce
n'était pas arrivé dans le district des
yvelines après des sensibilités il en
existe mais une agression elle que notre
collègue l'a vécu voilà ça faisait plus
de quatre ans était pas arrivé voilà je
pense quand même qu'on on a un corps
arbitral aussi qui je pense est une cda
en tout cas qui travaille en ce sens
pour que l'arbitrage soit de bonne
qualité et forcément en augmentant la
qualité des arbitres je pense aussi que
ça amène peut-être à ce que les choses
se passent au mieux en tout cas sur le
terrain on s'en aperçoit
on reste sur la même problématique dont
je parlais dès le départ des spectateurs
qui là ne sont ni maîtrisable par le
district ni par les clubs et où voilà on
a encore cette problématique là qui
reste pleine et entière et si une
solution existe je sus preneur et cette
année avec vous les gens perdent le
rayon en quelques secondes on
al'impression finalement c'est de la
sensibilisation et de la prévention qui
vous faire avant oui alors on en fait
quand même avant parce qu'on on passe
des messages aux éducateurs on passe des
messages au président de club on
explique les risques que prennent les
gens qui se comportent mal
comme je le disais
quand il ya des sanctions graves on en
fait état pour que les gens le sachent
faut savoir que depuis quelques années
les pvd commission de discipline on n'a
plus droit de publier ce qui fait que
évidemment dans notre journal ou sur
notre site internet on ne les voit pas
on ne les voit que de façon anonyme
lorsqu'on met en avant le fait que 1
arbitres a été agressée ou qu'il ya eu
quelque chose de vraiment très grave
mais c'est c'est vrai si on connaissait
je rejoins ce qui vient d'être dit si on
avait la solution il ya longtemps qu'on
l'aurait mise en oeuvre le carton blanc
je pense que chez les jeunes le carton
blanc il n'est pas assez utilisé le
carton blanc c'est l'exclusion
temporaire et il n'est pas assez utilisé
bon voilà je pense que et d'ailleurs
nous avons le faire le comité direction
du district vient d'être élu le 17
octobre ça se passait à
montigny-le-bretonneux et dans le plan
d'action de la liste qui a été élu et
que j'ai conduite et bien il y a le fait
de revenir au carton blanc justement à
l'exclusion temporaire chez les jeunes
parce que ça donnerait peut-être dans
toutes les catégories de jeunes le moyen
de 2 mètres pendant 10 minutes celui qui
est en train de s'installer et de
s'énerver le mettre dehors de se calmer
parce que pendant et pendant ce temps là
les l'équipe elle joue à dix ce qui fait
que ceux qui restent il joue à dix ils
sont pas contents de ce que vient de
faire leurs collègues qui est sur le
banc qu'ils y voyaient ce que je veux
dire
entre voilà c'est ça et donc c'est aussi
par des choses qui paraissent comme ça
très simple qu'on peut faire avancer les
choses dans le bon sens et c'est sur ces
mots qu'on va s'arrêter se
responsabiliser pour que le football
reste du football et reste toujours un
plaisir merci à tous les trois d'avoir
accepté cette invitation
vous pouvez revoir cette émission sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
il